>>> EVERY CHRISTMAS WE FIND
OURSELVES RETURNING TO THE OLD
BLACK AND WHITE CHRISTMAS
CLASSICS.
"THE CHRIS MATT CAROL," IT'S A
WONDERFUL LIFE OR, IF YOU'RE
PETE DAVIDSON "RAGING BULL."
HERE IS A PIECE WE FINISHED
FILMING AT 5:00 A.M. THIS
MORNING, "AN EVENING WITH PETE."
AND COLIN JOST, SORT OF.
>> ALL RIGHT, PETE.
YOU STILL GOT IT, BABY.
YOU'RE THE CHAMP.
YOU COULD STILL DO UPDATE WITH
THE BEST OF THEM.
>> FIVE MINUTES, MR. DAVIDSON.
>> I'LL BE THERE IN SIX.
>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M COLIN JOST.
HERE IS OUR RESIDENT YOUNG
PERSON, PETE DAVIDSON WITH HIS
THOUGHTS ON THE WORLD.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AS YOU KNOW, I AM FROM STATEN
ISLAND.
DO YOU GUYS KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GILL BEGAN'S ISLAND AND
STATEN ISLAND?
ONE IS FULL OF A BUNCH OF MORONS
WHO ARE STUCK THERE FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES, AND THE OTHER
ONE IS AN OLD TV SHOW.
>> DO CHAD!
>> NO.
NOT GOING TO DO THAT, PAL.
>> COME ON.
JUST DO CHAD.
>> YOU CAN'T JUST DO CHAD.
OKAY?
IT TAKES TWO PEOPLE.
IT IS LIKE A WHOLE THING.
>> COME ON.
JUST DO IT.
>> DO CHAD!
>> ALL RIGHT, FINE.
WANT CHAD, I'LL DO CHAD.
OKAY.
>> YEAH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> PETE DAVIDSON, EVERYONE.
♪♪ HI
♪♪ MY NAME IS WHAT
♪♪ MY NAME IS WHO
♪♪ WARREN BEATTY.
>> WHO IS THE AUDIENCE FOR THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THE GUY IS SWEATING LIKE A PIG.
>> YEAH.
HE EATS A WHOLE TURKEY BEFORE
COMING ON STAGE AT NIGHT.
>> GOD.
>> HEY, BOSS, SOME GUYS OUTSIDE
SAY HE KNOWS YOU.
HE'S TRYING TO JUMP THE LINE.
SAYS HE USED TO WRITE FOR YOU OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> HEY!
PETE, HEY IT'S YOUR OLD PAL
LENNY CORBIN.
>> NEVER SEEN HIM BEFORE IN MY
LIFE.
>> BUT WAIT, PETE.
WE SHARED AN OFFICE TOGETHER.
I WROTE ALL YOUR UPDATES AND
YOUR SKETCHES FOR YOU.
I STAYED UP ALL NIGHT WORKING
WHILE YOU WENT TO KNICKS GAMES.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT?
A MEDAL?
GET OUT OF HERE, YOU BUM.
SHUT THE DOOR.
>> IT'S OKAY, PETE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BUT JUST TEXT ME WHENEVER.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, I'D LIKE TO DO A SONG WITH
MY DEAR FRIEND MACHINE GUN
KELLY.
♪♪
>> I'LL TAKE THE FIRST VERSE.
SO THERE I WAS, COMPLETELY
DRESSED UP AS THE GRINCH ABOUT
TO GET IN A FIGHT WITH THAT NO
NECK GUY FROM "90 DAY FIANCÉE".
>> I GOT TO GO, ACTUALLY.
>> OKAY.
HOW ABOUT YOU, LADIES?
WOULD YOU LIKE ANOTHER DRINK?
♪♪
■
>> COLD NIGHT, HUH?
>> YEAH.
>> PETE?
>> COME ON, BUD.
WE HAVE A LOT OF CATCHING UP TO
DO.
♪♪
>> YOU GUYS KNOW HOW I WAS A
FAMOUS SEX SYMBOL FOR REASONS NO
ONE COULD UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS THE GUY THAT CAME UP
WITH THAT.
>> SERIOUSLY?
>> HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THAT?
>> WELL, I WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT AND I JOTTED IT
DOWN.
THE REST IS HISTORY.
>> WAS IT AWESOME, HIS IDEA TO
LIKE COVER YOUR BODY IN TATTOOS
AND THEN PAINFULLY REMOVE THEM
ONE BY ONE?
>> SURE.
LISTEN, EDDY, I KNOW YOU NEVER
GOT THE CREDIT YOU DESERVED, SO
I WANT YOU TO HAVE THIS.
IT'S ONE OF MY OSCARS.
>> OH, WOW.
VIOLA DAVIS LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT
AWARD.
PETE, WHERE DID YOU GET THIS?
>> WELL, DO YOU WANT IT OR NOT?
>> NO, THANK YOU.
>> WELL, FOLKS, IT'S BEEN A
GREAT NIGHT.
I HOPE YOU ALL HAVE A MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
AND, REMEMBER, IT'S NOT
CHRISTMAS WITHOUT FIREWORKS AND
HOT DOGS.
>> THAT'S 4th OF JULY, PETE.
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
ANYWAY, WE'VE COME TO THE END OF
THE SHOW, WHICH MEANS IT'S TIME
FOR ME TO SAY
♪♪ GOOD-BYE FOR NOW.
♪♪ WE'LL SEE EACH OTHER AGAIN
♪♪ YOU KNOW THAT I AM ALWAYS
NEAR
♪♪ YOU KNOW THAT I'LL BE WAITING
HERE FOR YOU, OH
♪♪ WAITING FOR YOU, OH
♪♪ THE PETE DAVIDSON SHOW
♪♪